and just as to chess and just as to
murders one I am so excited to be back
on injustice again I love the injustice
college oh my god the injustice comics
are so good and it's awesome because we
get Tom Taylor back in the stories again
okay okay so let's calm down let's calm
down let's relax you know suicide okay
so in injustice and justice to follows
the game like it follows the conclusion
of the game it gives us a little bit of
a time a little bit of time that kind of
laughs in between but not a whole lot I
mean it kind of you know fills in the
gaps a little bit but what it basically
tells us is it again
it's the rebuilding phase right like
Superman had been defeated by the forces
of Batman by the Justice League from a
different reality and it resulted in
Superman being held confined in a prison
with red Sun radiation of course red Sun
radiation effectively neutralizing his
power so the cool thing about this is
the Batman goes to visit Superman and
what really happens here is if it's
amazing because Superman really kind of
counters to Batman like the state of
where he's at and what direction he's
going in and this is kind of cool
because without Superman there the whole
totalitarian regime is effectively gone
but the funny thing about this is that
Superman wasn't wrong right like I mean
that was the whole philosophical
argument that we had and the first
injustice you know series of videos we
were basically making the argument early
I was making the argument that Superman
wasn't wrong in a world of war in a
world of conflict in a world of strife
all those kinds of things
Superman's strip people's freedom away
yes but replaced it with order and
structure and it really begs the
question if people have freedom and
people use that freedom to destroy
themselves then of what use does freedom
of what uses freedom to a dead man wars
are not won by the people who die wars
are won by the people who live long
enough to win the war and so it's really
kind of a cool concept when it comes to
like the whole injustice scenario and
the whole idea of what direction things
go in now because with Superman gone it
sets the stage for the world to return
back to the way it was to a degree but
the world's also broken in a lot of
different ways and remember the
governments of the world were forced to
kneel to the you know to Superman now
that Superman is gone the idea is okay
how do we return ourselves to the way we
were before which means that now people
are looking to the idea of like
corrupted government officials are
looking to the idea of petty squabbles
the world being as chaotic and
as you know screwed up as it was before
now the role of that man in this
particular you know post injustice year
five landscape is rebuilding how do you
rebuild the world in a way that makes
sense now the funny thing about this is
that Superman basically says you can't
rebuild the world on your own because a
world ruled by Batman would be crazy
like a world that's that's literally
molded in the image of Batman would be
nuts because imagine that you know
people would be terrified to commit
crimes I would dare say it'd be just
like Superman but by you know but
through a different means that they
would have his own police force and so
on and so forth so yes you know we're
preventing crime from happening but
we're basically still doing the exact
same thing that Superman is doing now of
course after this whole conversation
between the two of them basically comes
to an end the cool thing is that you
know Superman basically made the case of
simply saying hey look despite all your
bravado despite all your whole I'm
Batman I'm fighting against crime all I
can stuff he's really just a kid who's
trying to stop two bullets who's trying
to stop the bullets that killed his
parents and this resonates with Batman
because once he leaves he starts talking
to Harley Quinn's she's still very much
a part of the Batman landscape but I
guess you really kind of wanted Batman's
allies and he admits Superman is right I
can't rebuild the world on my own I need
people in my corner that can correct me
when I start making decisions that
should go awry and that's really the
huge difference between Batman here and
Superman an injustice you know in the
hole in justice landscape Superman
didn't listen to anybody else he did for
a time but fear governed Superman just
the reason why you know he reacted the
way he did with Lois Lane died that he
instilled this totalitarian regime is
the reason he fell to the to the
Sinestro Corps in the first place you
know as time progressed he became more
ruthless he became more cruel the
Justice League stopped being a group
that he confided in and began being a
group that he looked as basically a tool
to use to achieve his own goals now of
course the other half of this is Harley
Quinn herself and it's kind of funny
because Harley Quinn remains very much
just this bright funny character in this
story that's why I love Harley and
injustice she's so hilarious
but in the middle of basically calling
you know and talking to her sister about
you know Harley's daughter you know
talking about it being her birthday and
so on and so forth we end up having like
the cuivre the home base of Harley Quinn
blown to pieces only to find that she's
met with the arrival of Amanda Waller
now this is the coolest thing because we
had neither high nor hair to indicate
then Amanda Waller existed in the
injustice universe we didn't know what
was going on with her and we sort
we had no indication that the Suicide
Squad was there and so what ends up
happening is where Harley Quinn makes
her escape she's basically taken out by
Deadshot only for her to basically wake
up and be told by Amanda Waller welcome
to The Suicide Squad so this is awesome
because now we have the Suicide Squad in
the injustice universe which really begs
the question you know what kind of
scenario are we going to be seeing here
with regards to the whole Suicide Squad
concept not from here we pick back up
again with dr. fate and this is a
question that I didn't really get a
chance to answer when we were covering
the injustice stories because we didn't
really cover it but this really answers
the question of what happened with Black
Canary now the whole idea here is for
those of you guys who were you know part
of a whole injustice line of stories you
saw those videos when Black Canary had
been killed by Superman and the moments
before she was supposed to die she was
basically rescued by dr. fate and she
was transported to another reality and
the reason why was because dr. fate
really just kind of took pity on you
know dr. fate said hey look you know
you've fought for all the right things
you've lost everything so close to you
you know your son deserves a mother and
your son deserves a father and she and
he basically whisked her away to a
different reality where Oliver Queen had
survived but Black Canary had died
somewhere along the line and so what he
did is he basically took two different
versions of characters and paired them
together so we got black canary and we
got Oliver Queen from two different
universes now this is really kind of a
kind of harkening back to the old school
introduction of Black Canary because she
was from a different universe she was
from earth-2 I think it was and it's a
really weird history because there was
one point where Oliver Queen was dating
the mother of Black Canary and black
Canary herself at the same time he was
dating the mom and the daughter which I
mean it's kind of it's kind of cool when
you think about it but nonetheless he
was basically dating them both at the
same time and and the funny thing here
is again a little bit of humor they
still have Connor you know Connor was
brought over from the other universe
from the injustice universe and raised
by this reality's version of Oliver
Queen alongside the injustice universe
version of Black Canary but the idea
here is that dr. fate showing up is
basically saying hey look you guys need
to come back you guys have to return the
war is over Superman is lost it's time
to begin jumping into the rebuilding
phase and you guys are going to be
necessary for that so it's really just a
way for Tom Taylor to bring back Oliver
clean and bring back Black Canary which
makes sense because Oliver Queen went
out like a hero in the injustice
universe and people absolutely loved him
for it but it's good to see him come
back because what this does is it
basically takes the character that
doesn't know anything about the
injustice universe and it kind
we kind of get to live through the eyes
of Oliver Queen so to speak the cool
thing about this is jumping back to
Harley Quinn with her basically being
forced into the Suicide Squad
you know her argument is you could not
have made a more foolish mistake like
I'm an ally of that man like there are
people who do stupid things and then
there's what you've done here which is
probably the worst thing you could have
done now of course this also kind of
hits home to the nature of Amanda Waller
and the symphony manda Waller is very
arrogant Amanda Waller is very I do
things my way and either you're along
for the ride or you're done with all
your living but the funny thing about
this is that we basically have the
arrival of that man who winds up ticking
out the suicide squad except this is not
Batman this is a person dressed up as
Batman but this is not Batman mostly
because he's just wheeling two guns now
as far as I'm aware and in justice so
far we don't know who this guy is at
least as far as I've read as far as
you're concerned we don't know who this
guy is I mean there's all kinds of
different questions that are kind of
kind of being post here in terms of who
this guy is mostly because of the fact
that he shoots a multitude of people
issues Amanda Waller the whole nine
yards kills them all you know and
basically says you are now my Suicide
Squad now the funny thing about this is
it's also him basically thinning the
herd and this actually makes sense just
because of the fact to remember people
are shanghaied into the Suicide Squad
and bombs are planted in their heads to
keep them there if the reason why they
can't just leave or they don't just
rebel against Amanda Waller and kill her
but the crazy thing about this is that
whoever this guy is as posing his Batman
goes through and thinned the herd out I
mean he literally starts killing off a
whole bunch of the people who were here
because they serve no useful purpose now
this is Tom Taylor kind of thinning
things out right like we wouldn't expect
the clock King we wouldn't expect you
know William tockman to be a usable
member of The Suicide Squad what can he
do
of what purpose does he serve he's like
I was obsessed with clocks in time you
know it's different things like that
these guys are useless in almost every
sense of the word but you know he grabs
those who are useful you know Captain
Boomerang Deadshot captain Colt are
effectively brought on board now this
inevitably brings this false Batman into
direct confrontation with the real
Batman and this is beautifully done
because this false Batman immediately
overpowers Bruce Wayne and it's not even
a contest but notice here notice that
the notice the movements that he has
he's fluid he's trained in martial arts
he knows every single move that Bruce
Wayne's going to make any counters every
single one of them if I didn't know any
better I would say this is like Jason
Todd or somebody who trained a Bruce one
so again it's really kind of a cool
scenario because it begs the question
what's going on here how are things
unfolding who is this guy who's posing
as Batman now of course following this
this of course leads into the really the
introduction of Lucius Fox it leads into
Bruce Wayne recovering under the care of
Barbara Gordon but we also get a message
from Lex Luthor remember in the original
injustice stories Lex Luthor was a
friend to Superman before the events of
Lois Lane dying at the hands of the
Joker but when Superman basically became
a bad guy Lex Luthor secretly worked
against him in support of Batman and so
the two of them were basically allies
now the whole revelation of what Lex
Luthor was about all really kind of came
to a head in year 5 which results in Lex
Luthor basically being revealed as
having worked against Superman which
ultimately led to his death but because
the fact that Lex Luthor is no longer
there what he basically ended up doing
is he took all the money that he had all
the resources that he had and willed
them to Bruce Wayne so Bruce Wayne is
all the richer now but again Lex Luthor
reiterates the exact same thing that
Superman said he says look a world
molded in your image would be terrifying
what you need are allies you need allies
with money and you need allies with
ideas now again this is cool because
this really continued this is Tom Taylor
hitting home at the idea that Bruce
Wayne's not perfect Batman's not the
best good guy ever that man's an
antihero if Batman's not careful he'll
become Superman
and that's why this is so cool because
Superman tells them that Lex Luthor
tells them that the world tells him that
you cannot make the world in your image
because you are not perfect you're not
some benign godly being that knows
everything about everything and will
always make the right calls you make
mistakes you do the wrong thing this is
evident and in just this year one I mean
this is evident any justice year two
it's evident and injustice year three
and four and five
Batman consistently had opportunities to
take down Superman he consistently had
opportunities to work it out in a
different way but he constantly kept
coming back with his own insurgency you
know ultimately it led to the two of
them coming to blows which led to the
you know the whole of the injustice
event in the first place but the fact
remains here that this is again you know
kind of this idea being reiterated that
Bruce Wayne cannot make the world in its
own image now of course this also sees
why canary arrived alongside of the
alternate reality version of Green Arrow
this is really really cool here because
we get a little more information about
this
version of Oliver Queen we didn't really
know much you know know a whole lot
about him when he was first introduced
and we didn't need to at the time it was
just oh my god you know Black Canary
gets a good send-off she gets a nice
very well she gets a happily ever after
and that's all we needed because it was
just this one little shining ray of hope
in the original injustice line of
stories when all we got was just
darkness and death and sadness and so on
so forth what we find out is that this
version of Oliver Queen for whatever
reason lost everything he lost all his
money we don't really know what it does
it happened what we do know is that he
lost virtually everything but the
response to that man is well that may
have been in that universe but in this
universe none of that happened you're
still a billionaire and it's your money
and you know black Canary's money
because the two of you are married which
ultimately leads to Black Canary
proposing to him because of the fact
that in this universe they're not
technically married but again it's most
like these it's the small little
beautiful moments the Tom Taylor kind of
introduces into the story that keep
things fresh they keep things fun you
know that reminds us that the injustice
universe is not something devoid of
happiness the injustice universe is not
something filled with darkness and
sadness and that there are beautiful
things that come out of his humors these
small great little moments to take place
between these two characters because
when we think of Oliver Queen and black
Canary's you know they really go
together like like peas and carrots I
mean they are two people who are kind of
this hallmark of the superhero community
it's really kind of funny because we end
up having this scenario where of course
this alarm goes off you know we end up
picking up with the warden of the prison
that was created by that man a guy by
the name of Turpin which ultimately
reveals that the power to the prison has
been taken down now under normal
circumstances this wouldn't be a huge
deal and while it does have backup
generators those backup generators have
been disabled the reason why that's a
problem is because the red solar
radiation is powered by the prison if
that power goes down there's nothing to
keep Superman contained and so
ultimately Superman begins to break out
now of course the question has to be
asked here who took down power in the
first place and how did all this get
pulled off now of course we're Turpin
and his guys begin responding as best
they can while Batman in his career in
round we end up having this false Batman
show up again and the cool thing is that
this false atman basically has a Suicide
Squad go through and start taking out
all these different people who were
there now the initial indication is that
this false atman is going after Superman
basically saying hey look we have to
find Superman we have to get him out
that's the implication that's given to
us here ultimately of course we end up
having
Oliver Queen and we have Barbara Gordon
and black canary show up and basically
kind of you know save the day but again
a funny little bit of humor that's
interjected in here when Deadshot shows
up with the intention of taking out a
canary and taking out Barbara Gordon
they're all basically saved by Harley
Quinn but remember Harley Quinn was
basically kind of rescued you know from
the Joker rescue from the intention of
Superman to kill her by the original
Oliver Queen who died at the hands of
Superman and so with him being here
Harley just kind of thrown back to the
idea of oh my god you're alive it's a
beautiful hilarious moment here because
we actually have this funny scenario
where the question is asked by Oliver
Queen like like what's the deal like
worried friends here or something like
that Harley's like no we weren't just
friends we were lovers
which of course she's just Leslie
whatever is hilarious to see the
responses it's hilarious to see Oliver
Queen just kind of freaking out again
getting back into serious things we pick
up a Batman confronting Superman and
this is absolutely genius and it's one
of the things that I love about this
Batman is a superhero who usually phase
of every possible scenario you know he
thinks of every single situation that
can either benefit or work against him
in the case of Superman if he ever were
to get three and ever were to get out
into the solar radiation of the Yellow
Sun that the earth orbits it would
result in him being restored back to
full power and if that were the case
there'd be almost no way for Batman to
take him out again or at least that
seems to be the case but again this is
Batman basically saying hey look we had
contingencies like you did you really
believe that I wouldn't account the
power going down like the most logical
scenario you really believe I wouldn't
account for that I mean it's the most
expected thing to happen that somewhere
along the line power would fail or
somebody would break in take down the
generators this kind of thing was
planned for and so what Bruce Wayne had
done as he had contacted the atom and
literally had the atom enter the ear
canal of Superman with a shard of green
kryptonite to keep him under control
sheer genius
it's a beautiful bit of thinking because
it's this idea the Batman has genuinely
thought of a lot of different scenarios
by which to take Superman down now of
course this continues to beg the
question what's going on with this evil
version of Batman what in the world is
happening here well of course when this
evil Batman shows up the scenario let's
put forward by Harley Quinn of look I
mean I have to go because I'm part of
the Suicide Squad but we were never here
for Superman we were here for Damian
Wayne and this is when we find out that
this is all just a ruse and what this
shows us is that this evil version of
Batman is
every bit as intelligent as Bruce Wayne
and so what we end up having is Talia al
Ghul alongside some unnamed girl now of
course with rescuing Damian Wayne what
this also does is this keeps in mind the
loyalty of Damian Wayne because remember
with Damian's character in the original
injustice series it was interesting with
him guess because of the fact that for
him he was consistently torn between
loyalties I mean he looked to Batman and
said look I mean you're the guy who
raised me you're my dad you taught me
everything I knew but he also allied
himself with Superman because he agreed
with Superman's vision but Damian Wayne
still had loyalties he still had
loyalties to his friends he still had
loyalties to the Justice League and so
while they were all held captive and
while they're all still held captive any
intention of Talia al Ghul is to break
Damian Wayne out of prison his response
is we have to rescue everybody else they
are my allies
I remain honorable I stay true to my
allies now of course this offers
basically turned down Turpin and those
guys who show up or all killed
and Damian Wayne has taken away what we
end up finding out is that this woman
who came alongside Talia al Ghul is a
girl by the name of a pan Asia the
daughter of the bat presumably the
daughter of Bruce Wayne Wow without
being said guys close fighters what I
think I got we're going to bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come as explained make sure you guys are
the sub button to become part of the Rob
port if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]